JOE BEDA: Hello my name
is Joe Beda and
welcome to Session 313.
This is the technical details
or sort of advanced Google
Compute Engine.
And in this session we're going
to be going over in a
little bit more depth the
different parts of a Google
Compute Engine, given a little
bit more meat on the bones of
how things work.
We're going to show some
examples of real world
applications and experiences.
And then I'm going to take some
time to dig into some of
the details that make Google
Compute Engine interesting and
how to get the best use
out of the product.
My little remote.
This isn't good.
There we go.
OK.
So just a little
bit of review.
I want to cover what exactly
Compute Engine is.
It's infrastructure as a service
provided by Google.
And when people think
infrastructure, they usually
start thinking about
virtual machines.
And it's a very important part
of what we're doing.
But it's only part
of the picture.
So we're going to cover the
virtual machines, but I also
want to talk about the network
storage and tools that go
along with that.
This completes the picture.
And I think we have interesting
offerings at each
of these levels.
And we're launching in limited
preview today.
And as part of that limited
preview we're concentrating on
large computationally intensive
batch workloads.
And as we continue to develop
the product, we're going to
expand the scope of that
program and the type of
workloads that we take on and
are appropriate for running on
Compute Engine.
So one of the things that I
think really makes Compute
Engine interesting is that it
builds on top of Google's
infrastructure and Google's
experiences.
And this really breaks down
four different ways.
So the first thing
is one of scale.
And I think you saw this very
dramatically with [? Orze's ?]
keynote this morning about
sort of how much scale we
really have at Google.
And we're really excited to
start bringing some of that
capacity online so that
you can start taking
advantage of it.
The next thing is speed.
Google's infrastructure is
optimized for search.
This is an industry where one
millisecond translates to
millions of dollars.
And we've spent years optimizing
our infrastructure
both at the software and
hardware level, and especially
our networking systems, to be
able to provide low latency,
high bandwidth, enormous
services, at a
really unique scale.
And there's no other provider
out there that actually brings
together that level of scale,
that global footprint, and the
comprehensive set of services
that we have.
The next thing is really
our global footprint.
And this is not just in terms of
where we have data centers
and where we have presence.
It's really about
our networking.
And this comes into play in so
many different ways in terms
of communicating between virtual
machines that are in
different regions or how your
traffic gets from your virtual
machine to any end user
out on the internet.
And finally, we have a
comprehensive and growing and
well integrated platform
of services.
And this stretches from
everything from App Engine to
Google Cloud Storage to Big
Query to Translate to Maps and
all sorts of other APIs.
And Google Compute Engine
complements these by allowing
you to run your code in a
familiar environment close to
where these API endpoints are.
So I want to review you a little
bit-- if you were at
the earlier talk, Craig
McLuckie's talk, he covered
some of this stuff.
But I want to go over it
again very quickly.
What are the things that we
thought about as we built
Compute Engine?
And I think you'll see these
themes really reoccur as we
give some concrete examples.
So the first thing here is that
we built Compute Engine
to be as secure as possible
from the get-go.
We really thought about security
deeply, even in the
very early days of
the product.
And this really manifests itself
in terms of providing a
secure, isolated virtual network
for each individual
application or project to
encrypting all data at risk as
it is written to or read from
with the virtual machine.
The next thing is we want things
to be open and flexible
and familiar.
And this applies both at
the control layer.
Our API, while it's a Google
Compute Engine specific API,
we've built it to leverage
well-known
concepts and to be familiar.
But also within the virtual
machine we provide a familiar
environment that you
can get up and
running as quick as possible.
The next point is really
around consistency.
If you build an application, and
you test it, and it works,
you want to actually feel
that it's going
to continue to work.
And so Google has a deep
expertise in terms of running
shared workloads internally
across all of our
infrastructure for our
own applications.
And we've applied a lot of the
same technology there to
actually provide a really
amazing level of consistency
for our virtual machine
product.
And finally, we want you to
know-- well, not finally.
We have two more points--
proven.
We're running real workloads on
this infrastructure today.
And we're going to have an
example in this talk from one
of our early usages
internally.
But this is not a
beta product.
This is actually something
that is in use.
There's real Google revenue
flowing through this product
today, and we're offering this
same exact product to you.
And then finally, we want to
actually enable an ecosystem.
We want to be able to have
partners and be able to
leverage open source systems
that already exist.
And again, this is either from
outside the system at the API
level, but also what's running
inside the virtual machine.
So to jump right in, I'm going
to invite up Evan Anderson
who's another member of our team
to give you a quick Hello
World type demo.
Evan?
EVAN ANDERSON: So I'm going to
be using our command line
tools to start up a new virtual
machine and then show
you a little bit about how the
API works and login, show you
a few features.
And you can do all of these same
things through our web
API, through our web UI.
But in this case, I'm going to
use the command line so that
you can sort of see
a little bit more
about how things happen.
So each virtual machine has a
name and you can associate--
you may have seen
[? Chris Eych's ?]
talk earlier--
various permissions
with each VM.
So in this case, I'm going to
say that I want access to
Google Storage and I want it
to be read write access.
And it will prompt
me saying, OK.
Which of these zones would you
like to launch your virtual
machine in, and which
virtual machine type
would you like to launch?
So I'm going to launch
a four-CPU VM.
And we've submitted the request
to start this instance.
And our API says, OK.
This is instance is in the
process of being started.
You can query and get the
status of this instance.
And you can see that right
now it is staging.
And you can also use this tool
while you're sort of debugging
or figuring out how this API
works, to actually get the
JSON output.
And you can see there's a bunch
of properties that the
summary tells you the
interesting useful stuff if
you're a person.
But you may be interested
in things like an
ID if you're a program.
So I'm going to SSH into this
VM and install a software
package called Context Free,
which is used to generate
algorithmic graphics.
So this is just a standard
Ubuntu Linux VM.
And I've got access to all
of the Ubuntu packages.
Obviously, I could also build
something of my own.
And I'm going to generate a
2000 by 2000 image of a
Sierpinski gasket that is one
of the context-free demos.
And so my virtual machine is
going, generating a bunch of
fractals and it's done.
One other thing I'll note, we
talked earlier about how I
named this virtual
machine Demo.
You can see that the host
name is actually
also set to be demo.
We do this via DHCP, so it
should work with most standard
Linux installations.
And I could just copy this
back or run Apache or
something like that to show
you how this works.
But I'm going to actually copy
this to Google Storage that I
gave permissions to earlier and
make it publicly readable
so anyone can see it.
And so this gets copied.
And as you can see, it's the
only one and a half megabytes,
so it's pretty fast.
And then we can go and look at
it at common data storage.
And this should load after
a few moments.
And here is the Sierpinski
triangle.
As you can see, access to Google
Storage is a little bit
faster from this virtual
machine than
it is from my laptop.
But it's loading.
And I think we left
the wireless on.
JOE BEDA: That's the mistake.
EVAN ANDERSON: Oh,
that would do it.
That would do it.
So as you'll note when we're
interacting with most of this
stuff, we've been using Google
Storage because it's close and
it's local and not using stuff
on your local workstation,
because it's further way.
And with that, we'll let Joe
get back to the slides.
And Joe will tell you a bit more
about how that actually
comes to be.
JOE BEDA: Actually, I'm going
to-- you'll have excuse me for
a second here.
Let's go through and turn
off the wireless.
I am plugged in here, so let's
keep our fingers crossed.
OK.
So thank you, Evan.
Hopefully that gives you a taste
of how Compute Engine
works, and the familiar
environment, and then also
some of the seamless
connections to
other Google services.
We're going to go into a lot
more detail on a lot of what
you just saw.
But I just wanted to jump
in real quick there.
So let's cover the
architecture of
Google Compute Engine.
So I'm going to talk about all
the main pieces and how they
fit together and give you
as much detail as I can
fit into this talk.
And so I have a diagram
that shows--
and this is based on the diagram
that Craig had in his
earlier talk.
But I'm going to go through
this piece by piece and as
much detail as I can here.
So it really starts
with the API.
And this is the model for the
different things that you can
touch, and mess with,
and modify, and
inspect with the system.
And this is an adjacent
over HTTP API.
It's REST inspired.
And you're authorized to that
with OAuth 2, like pretty much
every other API at Google.
And the concepts here
are very familiar.
I think there's probably
one or two new
things on this list.
And we can cover those.
But we tried not to reinvent
the wheel in terms of the
basic structure and concepts of
an infrastructure service.
So calling this API is you can
always be a real hacker and
write your JSON by
hand into telnet.
But most people want some
help doing that.
And so you saw the command
line tool that
Evan was using earlier.
We're not going to cover
it in this talk, but we
also have a web UI.
And then we have a
set of libraries.
And these are both the standard
Google API libraries
that work across a whole
slew of APIs.
But we've also worked to build
a very easy-to-use
Python-based API that's really
hand-tuned to provide a great
experience.
All of these things are open and
they use the API directly.
So we're not cheating and going
around and making an end
run and using special calls.
So the API really is the
interface to the product.
And that web UI itself is built
on top of App Engine.
So this is a great example of
how App Engine can drive the
Google Compute Engine API to
provide orchestration or
administration.
And finally, we have partners
and an ecosystem.
And so they're using the API
itself to actually be able to
provide services on top of
Compute Engine on your behalf.
And so if you were at the
previous talk, you saw the
demo from RightScale.
But we've also been working
with puppet and ops code.
And there's a whole slew of
systems built up around cloud
management that are welcome to
use this API and we hope to
really foster an ecosystem
there.
And so that's both, again, at
the API level but also what's
going on inside the
virtual machine.
Now, there's this concept
of a project.
And everything that happens in
Compute Engine happens within
the context of a project.
Evan in his example actually had
sort of an any file set up
so that there was a default
project there.
And the project is a container
for all these resources.
There's a set of members
that are
associated with that project.
In some ways, it's very similar
to an App Engine app.
But the idea here is that these
things are owned by the
project, not by people.
And so whenever there is an
action on the API, it's
actually traced back to a person
instead of an anonymous
set of credentials.
And so, actually, keeping this
sort of identity of who's
operating with the API is, we
think, a very unique and
powerful feature.
And if the API is sort of the
front door to the product, the
virtual machine is definitely
the heart of
what we're doing here.
And so we're offering Linux
virtual machines.
You get root access
on these machines.
You saw Evan install a
package from Ubuntu.
And one thing that we should
note is that we are locking
down the Linux kernel.
And this is really for reasons
of security and performance.
We've actually tuned that kernel
to work very well with
our networking environment.
And we're offering a couple
stock images based off of
Ubuntu and sentOS.
And you're free to customize
these and build your own
custom images.
Or if you're a real hacker, you
can build your own Linux
distribution by hand
carving bits.
And so our images, we've done
a couple of things.
We've installed a couple of
utilities by default, things
like the GSUtil that Evan was
calling, just so that stuff is
ready to go.
And we've done a little bit of
security lock down, things
like turning off password
authentication and only
relying on SSH keys or turning
on automatic security updates.
Now, what do you get when you
actually buy a virtual machine
from Google Compute Engine?
Well, the first thing is that
you're getting a really
impressively fast Intel 2.6
gigahertz Sandy Bridge
processor, Xeon processor.
We offer these things in one,
two, four, and eight virtual
CPU configurations.
And we map one of these virtual
CPUs to a hyperthread.
And so if you get a two CPU
instance, you'll get both
halves of a real
physical core.
We're offering 3.75 gigabytes
of RAM per virtual CPU.
And that scales up linearly.
And we're offering a significant
amount of what
we're calling ephemeral
or local storage.
And if you buy one of the
bigger instances--
these are the four or the
eight core instances--
you also are provided with
dedicated spindles.
And so this actually comes
back to this level of
consistency.
If you know that you're the only
one reading and writing
from that disc, you're going to
get a lot more predictable
performance.
As part of this launch, we're
defining a new performance
metric called a Google Compute
Engine unit, or the GQ I think
is the cute name for it.
And we've built this to
approximate an ECU as best we
could figure it.
And so as far as we can
determine, we're rating our
virtual CPUs at 2.75 GQs
per virtual CPU.
And we're also working on
smaller machine types for
prototyping and debugging.
And so those will
be forthcoming.
I want to got into a little
bit of detail of sort of
what's going on under the covers
and the technology
stack that we've chosen and
what we're building on.
You may not know it but Google
actually has a great kernel
engineering team.
We actually of a lot expertise
with the Linux kernel.
And we really leveraged these
guys when we started looking
at which virtualization
technology we
wanted to build on.
And we ended up going with a
combination of kernel virtual
machines, or KVM, and
Linux cgroups.
So KVM is really a great and
relatively recent entrance
into the virtualization world.
And it's interesting because it
actually reuses the Linux
kernel to actually play the
role of hypervisor.
And so you end up reusing the
Linux memory manager and
scheduler to actually manage the
memory and the scheduling
of the virtual machines.
So one of the great advantages
that you get out of this is
that you can run both
virtualized and
non-virtualized workloads on
the same kernel and perhaps
even on the same machine.
And so with a number of machines
that Google manages,
having one single kernel that we
deploy and that we test, is
a huge, huge advantage.
So we worked closely with Red
Hat, and we really appreciate
the leadership that they've
shown in terms of getting KVM
where it's at today.
And we're going to be looking to
engage further with Red Hat
and the KVM community.
So stay tuned as we detail
our involvement there.
Now, the other piece of this
puzzle is this feature called
Linux cgroups.
So KVM provides virtualization.
Cgroups provides resource
isolation.
And this is something that
was pioneered by the
Google kernel team.
And it's been released to open
source for quite a while now.
And it's used a very, very
widely at Google.
So this is an example of Google
reusing technology that
we've built to solve some of
our own problems across our
own set of requirements, but
reapplying this into the
virtualization world.
And so we have a lot of
experience in terms of making
sure that we can keep workloads
isolated from each other.
And Linux cgroups is
a big part of that.
So moving away from the virtual
machines themselves, I
want to talk a little bit
about our networking.
So each project gets its own
private, virtual network.
You don't share this virtual
network with anybody else.
And this virtual network
actually spans across all of
your virtual machines, no
matter where they are.
So we think that's a really
interesting property.
So that means that if you have
a virtual machine running in
the East Coast of the United
States, and you have another
one running in Central US-- and
they can be hundreds or
thousands of miles away--
they can talk to each other
over this secure private,
virtual network.
And all that traffic, instead of
going through the Wild West
of the internet, actually goes
over Google's highly-managed
secure private network.
Inside of this virtual network,
you're going to see
private IP addresses,
RFC 1918 addresses.
These are like 10 dot
type of addresses.
And this network is all our IP
Layer 3 level networking.
So that means that you can be
sure that if you get a packet,
and it comes from a particular
IP address, that it really
came from that virtual machine
on your private network.
Now beyond these sort of flat
geographical regions, which we
think is a great feature, we've
also worked to actually
bridge the gap between the API,
what's happening at the
API level, and what's happening
inside the virtual machine.
And so, as you saw with Evan's
demo, when we name a virtual
machine demo-- or you name it
Foo or whatever you want to
name it, Worker Number 37--
that gets propagated into the
virtual machine so it becomes
that virtual machine's
host name.
Not only do we do that, but we
actually overlay the DNS
that's provided to that virtual
machine so that your
virtual machines can use those
host names to find each other.
When you're actually bringing up
a distributed system naming
is a really, really hard
thing to get right.
And it's really important, and
it's really useful to actually
have this system provide sort
of that substrate of naming
that you can take
advantage of.
This is actually a lesson that
Google's learned well as we've
built larger and
larger systems.
Moving away from the private
virtual network, I want to
talk about how our virtual
machines get
access to the internet.
So every virtual machine can be
assigned an IP address, and
it gets full use of
that IP address.
It won't show up if you do like
ifconfig inside the VM.
But instead, as your traffic
exits or enters from your
virtual network to the internet,
we actually rewrite
that IP address using NAT.
We're calling this 1-to-1 NAT
because it's not doing the
port mapping that you'll find is
relatively common with NAT.
These external IP address
is similar to the global
footprint of our virtual
networks, actually float
between regions also.
So this means that you can
actually detach an IP address
from a VM running in one region
and reattach it to
another VM running in a
different region that may be
hundreds or thousands
of miles away.
And Google automatically takes
care of making sure that the
traffic gets to the
right destination.
In addition, we have a built-in
firewall system so
that, again, this threat of
security, we want to make sure
that as you start your virtual
machine you don't get any
surprises with respect
to traffic
that you're not expecting.
And this utilizes,
again, Google's
global network footprint.
And so what happens is that no
matter where in the world this
traffic is coming from, as soon
as we can, we get it on
to Google's network, and it gets
a first class ticket from
wherever in the world it is
to your virtual machine.
And so instead of actually
dealing with sort of the chaos
that is the internet at large,
we try and actually eliminate
that to provide as much
consistency, as much
performance as we
possibly can.
So, again, this brings
in consistency.
We want to make sure that
we can provide a great
experience, no matter what's
going on with respect to the
weather of the network
currently.
And then finally a couple of
limitations I want to mention.
We're restricting outgoing email
access, SMTP traffic, as
an abuse measure.
If you have a need for that,
we're going to evaluate it on
a case-by-case basis.
And while you can do any sort
of IP level traffic between
instances on the private virtual
network, we're only
supporting UDP, TCP, and ICMP
for network traffic to the
internet at large.
So shifting away from
networking, I want to talk
about storage.
It's probably as important, if
not more important, than
networking.
And so the first thing I want
to highlight is what we've
been calling Persistent Disk.
So this is storage that builds
on top of Google's deep
experience with storage
infrastructure and provides a
virtual hard drive
that outlives the
lifetime of your instance.
And we've built this from the
ground up to be as fast and as
consistent as we possibly can.
We've really sort of started
measuring things out to like
the 99.999th percentile
and looking at
the latencies there.
And so this is provisioned
just like instances.
So whereas Evan called
[? GCU ?]
[? add ?] instance, you can
call add disk also.
And these things are actually
located within a zone, similar
to instances also.
And you can mount these things
read, write to a single
instance or you can mount
them read, write a
whole bunch of instances.
And we think that being able to
actually have a static data
set that you can mount
read only is a
really interesting feature.
We're also encrypting all of
the data coming from your
virtual machine before it
actually gets written anywhere
persistently.
And this is a really important
feature for
just peace of mind.
And because we're building on
these newer processors, we can
do this with essentially very
little to no overhead.
And so it's essentially
transparent to you.
We're making sure that your data
gets encrypted before it
gets written down.
OK.
So a number I want to share with
respect to consistency
and the persistent disk product,
we've measured this
in less than 3% variance on I/O
bandwidth when doing 4K
random reads and writes.
And with local disk you can
actually see this very by up
to the 13%.
So this is very, very
consistent.
Not only that, but when you're
doing large block read and
writes you can actually see
up to, I think, triple the
overall bandwidth as what you
would get to local disk.
And so we're really, really
proud of this persistent disk
product we're really happy
with where it's at.
But sometimes you don't need
that persistent data.
Sometimes, you need something
local that's sort of cheap and
cheerful, I think, was the
phrase that Craig used.
And in that case we have local
storage or ephemeral storage.
This is tied to your instance.
It lives and dies with
the instance.
Currently, all of our
instances are
booting off of this.
We're going to be looking at
putting off of the persistent
disk product in the future, and
you get a lot of it, up to
three and a half terabytes
with the 8 CPU instance.
And again, with the larger
instances, you're going to get
dedicated spindles, one
spindle with the 4 CPU
instance and then two spindles
with the 8 CPU instance.
And just like the persistent
disk, we encrypt this at rest.
And that key that actually
encrypts it actually never
leaves the machine that
the VM's sitting on.
Now I also want to talk about
Google Cloud Storage.
Now this isn't part of Google
Compute Engine proper.
But it's kind of a sister
product that we've worked well
to integrate with.
And this is an internet
object store.
It has its own HTTP API
for getting and
setting values into it.
And it's a great service for
getting data in and out of
Google's cloud.
You don't have to think about
managing your data.
It's really a lot of automatic
sort of management replication
happening for you.
And we have this feature that
I'm going to talk to a little
bit later-- and I think you saw
with it with Evan's demo
called service accounts--
that really make it frictionless
to use this.
You don't have to think about
propagating credentials and
making sure that those don't
leak and things like that.
And so Google Cloud Storage
also takes advantage of
Google's global infrastructure.
And not only do you get that
first class ticket for your
packets to anywhere
in the world, but
you also get caching.
So if your objects are publicly
readable, we can
cache them very close to where
they're going to be used.
And you get like CDN-type
performance out of that.
And then finally, I
mentioned zones.
I just want to mention this
for completeness.
We have this idea of
a region, which is
geography and routing domain.
And then we also have a zone,
which is really all about
fault tolerance.
For this limited preview, we're
launching in three zones
spread across the Central and
Eastern United States.
And we're going to be looking
to expand that
as the product develops.
So with that, that's sort of the
basics of the overview of
systems for Google
Compute Engine.
But I'd like to give you a real
idea of what it looks
like to run an application
on top of Compute Engine.
And with that I'd like to
introduce Hamza Kaya, who is
with Invite Media, to tell us
about his experience of
working with Compute Engine.
Hamza?
HAMZA KAYA: Thank you, Joe.
Hello everybody.
Invite Media is in a demand-side
platform that
allows advertisers to
buy from multiple ad
exchanges in real time.
Since everything happens in
real time, we have to deal
with two main challenges.
The first one is we need to
buy as many ad requests as
possible to multiple
ad exchanges.
As you can imagine, this results
in a very high volume
of traffic.
To give you an idea, Invite
these days handles close to
400K queries per second.
And the second challenge is that
we need to return a valid
response back to the
exchange within a
very short time period.
Usually this is 150
milliseconds, including the
network [INAUDIBLE]
time.
Handling many ad requests with
these short period of time is
definitely a challenging task
and requires good computing
power and a consistently
good networking.
Invite Media has been using
the same infrastructure
provider since the beginning.
And recently, we started to
evaluate Google Compute Engine
as an alternative.
Initially we wanted to build a
test cluster on Google Compute
Engine to see how teams
are working on
Google Compute Engine.
And what we saw was
pretty familiar to
our existing system.
Basically you have instances
running Linux.
And you can attach disks.
You can assign static IPs.
You can provide a
start-up script.
And you have a nice
API, which is
well-documented and easy to use.
With this familiar model, we
managed to port our system to
Google Compute Engine, and it
was fairly simple and quick.
We only spent two weeks of
engineering time to build a
fully functional cluster and
start serving traffic on
Google Compute Engine.
And honestly, two weeks is the
time we usually spend whenever
we need to expand our operation
to another region
within our existing provider.
So I'd like to share some of the
results that we achieved
through our initial test run.
So after we set up the test
cluster we decided to actually
serve a portion of our
production traffic through
Google Compute Engine.
And we used 8 core instances on
both our existing provider
and the Google Compute Engine.
On our existing provider a
single 8 core instance can
handle up to 250 queries per
second, while respecting the
latency requirements.
And on the other hand, on
Google Compute Engine, a
single instance can handle up
to 650 queries per second.
And that's pretty impressive.
And with that we used to serve
that portion of traffic with
284 machines.
Whereas after migrating to
Google Compute Engine, we are
currently serving with only
140 machines, which is
essentially halving our
number of servers
that we need to manage.
Another point that I want to
talk about is we have observed
a consistently good network
performance on
Google Compute Engine.
When we receive an ad request
we have 10 milliseconds to
find out an available back end
server and establish a
connection to it.
When we fail to establish a
connection in 10 milliseconds,
this usually counts as
a connection error.
With our current provider,
we usually have 5%
of connection errors.
So we error out 5%
of our requests.
With Google Compute Engine, this
error rate decreased to
under a half percent.
So that's quite an
achievement.
And another point is that with
our current provider, we time
out 11% off incoming requests,
which means that we cannot
return a response back
to exchange within
the given time limit.
On Google Compute Engine, this
error rate decreased to 6%,
which means that, essentially,
we have now 5% more ad
requests that we can buy
for our advertisers.
After seeing these results, we
decided to migrate our entire
operation to Google
Compute Engine.
And currently, we are in the
process of moving globally to
Google Compute Engine.
With that, I end.
That's all I have
to say today.
Thank you, Joe.
JOE BEDA: Thank you
very much, Hamza.
And I really appreciate you
being an early user of the
system and giving us a lot
of great feedback.
So the next example that we want
to give is a system that
was written by, actually, an
intern that started with us
about a month ago named
Dustin Carlino.
He's back in Seattle.
And this is a sample
application-- we're going to
be releasing the code for that--
for running Hadoop on
top of Compute Engine.
And I'd like to introduce Evan
again to run through how the
system works.
Evan?
EVAN ANDERSON: So I'm going to
start by outlining how the
application is designed.
And then we will actually start
up a Hadoop cluster.
And we'll run a job.
And all of this code, as Joe
mentioned, is going to be
released as example code
in the future.
So I'm going to go through this
a little bit quickly.
But you will have a chance later
to actually pore over
the code and see how
all of it works.
So the design allows for either
a command line or an
App Engine front end to talk
to the Google Compute API.
And the first step is to launch
a coordinator instance,
which we package up some data
and we push it to Google
Compute Engine.
And then, it starts up and
begins configuring itself.
And once the coordinator has
launched, it exposes a REST
JSON API, which can be used to
actually set up the rest of
the cluster.
So we're using one virtual
machine to drive the setup of
all of the other virtual
machines and provide
monitoring, and status
information, and so forth.
So right now, the coordinator
just started running.
So it will take a few minutes
for it to download all of the
packages it needs, and start
up, and get the actual
application service running.
This is booting from a fresh
Ubuntu image like in my
previous demo.
There is no special software,
except for what's running
after in this coordinator
bundle.
And Joe will talk more
about how that works.
So the controller is up.
And now, I'm going to request
that this coordinator start up
the rest of the cluster.
And so starting up the Hadoop
cluster involves requesting
that the coordinator download
all the Hadoop software, and
then stage it on to Google
storage so that all the rest
of the nodes can read it very
quickly, and also so that we
don't overwhelm our friendly
local Apache mirror.
So we've built a cluster
that's only about
100 nodes or so.
But we've requested
the coordinator
start spinning up nodes.
And as you can see, it's keeping
track of all of the
nodes that it's already launched
and the status of the
nodes that have been launched.
They are moving from
provisioning to staging and
you'll see some other steps.
And then it's launching
additional ones through the
API when it decides
that things are
making enough progress.
So all of this work is being
done on the coordinator node.
If I were to kill this script,
the coordinator would just
keep going along setting
up the cluster.
As you can see, several
of these nodes
have gotten to running.
Running means that the virtual
machine has booted, and it's
downloading Java.
It's downloading Hadoop.
It's installing Java
and Hadoop.
It's waiting for the agent
to start running on these
machines, which we use for
additional control that the
coordinator uses.
And that's this snitch
ready state.
The script will exit once it
has a sufficient quorum of
nodes available.
So you can see the Hadoop
name node just came up.
And now it's ready to
be part of Hadoop.
The JobTracker is
still coming up.
Once the JobTracker and the
NameNode are up, and there are
enough slaves, the script
will say, OK.
You can start launching Hadoop
jobs now, even though the rest
of the cluster isn't up yet.
So it's just going to finish
now, because it says, hey,
we've got some slaves up.
And we've got the Hadoop
masters up.
So that's enough for
you start running
Hadoop jobs if you want.
And as I said, all this will be
available as sample code.
But one of the nice additional
features of having this
separate controller is that you
can ask it, hey, what's
the status of the cluster?
And you can see now
we have something
like 41 Hadoop nodes.
And as they make progress--
we still have 44.
But that's fine.
44 is enough to start
our job with.
And as the rest come online
they will just
get added to cluster.
So I'm going to launch a job
on the Hadoop master that--
wow, I just got really
loud, sorry.
I'm going to launch a job on
the Hadoop master that
downloads 60 gigs of compressed
XML data of
Wikipedia revisions.
And then it--
sorry.
So we'll go and take a look at
that in the JobTracker first,
and then I will explain
how it works.
And I don't want to let this
go too long because Hadoop
will make short work of
it with 94 nodes.
So one note, it looks like
it's still setting up.
But this downloads 60
gigs of compressed
Wikipedia edit history.
And this is all the history of
Wikipedia for the last several
years of all the edits
that have been made.
And you could do a lot of
interesting stuff with this,
training machine learning,
training language algorithms,
analyzing social graphs,
or other sorts of
behavior like that.
And you can see we're
22% done right now.
And this has a tendency, because
it's only got 300 jobs
or so to run, to jump at the end
as all the jobs get done
at the same time.
We just went from 22 to 77%.
So this slices all the Wikipedia
data up into CSV
format, which is great for
exporting to Google Big Query.
And I will show you in a moment
how that would work
once you've done that.
Obviously, you could run other
interesting algorithms.
And you can see here
the job is done.
It took one and 1/2 minutes.
And we wrote 70 gigabytes
of data into HTFS
at the end of this.
So now if we load this data into
Google Big Query, we can
ask some interesting questions
like, which Wikipedia articles
have had the most
edits over time?
And so we say OK.
And you can see that there
are a lot of potentially
controversial topics here.
And if we look through the
results, we'll see, oh hey,
there's some interesting
things here.
It looks like people are more
interested in making edits on
Britney Spears' page than they
are about the Catholic Church.
So who's been making
all these edits?
Well, with Big Query you can
dig in and you can find the
top editors of the Britney
Spears page.
And obviously, you
could do lots of
other interesting things.
The great thing with Big Query
is it lets you do these sorts
of interactive, hey, I wonder,
sorts of questions.
And then that can guide your
later development of
additional Hadoop jobs to
mine interesting data.
So we discover some interesting
patterns doing a
couple of queries, and we say,
I wonder if that's true for
all Wikipedia users?
Well, now you can build your
Hadoop job, and you can find
the answer in a couple
of minutes.
And with that, I'm going to let
Joe get back to talking
about how all of this is put
together and the magic and
unique features behind the
scenes that let you do this
seamlessly.
JOE BEDA: Thank you
very much, Evan.
I think that does a great job of
showing how Google Compute
Engine to run familiar code to
actually solve new problems,
yet also integrate with the
other set of cloud services
that we're offering.
So I want to talk about some of
the features that actually
makes this possible.
And I think we've alluded to
this a couple times, but I
want to go into some detail on
what a service account is.
Like I said, every call that
actually comes into the Google
API, and pretty much any API, is
based on OAuth 2, and it's
tied back to a user.
But what if you want to make a
call to that API from code?
Right.
Would you take your
Gmail password and
put it in your VM?
That's probably not
a great idea.
So instead, what we did is we
invented this concept called
Service Accounts.
And this is a synthetic identity
for VMs and codes.
Your code actually sort
of is its own user.
And hopefully, maybe one day
it'll come and take over, and
decide they don't
need the humans.
But the great example here is
Google Compute Engine calling
other Google APIs, whether
that be Google Storage or
whether it be the task
queue pull API, which
is part of App Engine.
And then App Engine also support
Service Accounts.
And so you can use App Engine to
call the Google Compute API
to do all sorts of interesting
orchestration.
And so we think that these
things really complement each
other, and it actually stitches
together to make a
great seamless platform.
So here's some--
let's just put some meat
on the bones here.
You've seen some of this syntax
already when Evan
launched his first example.
When we launch a virtual
machine, we're providing the
Service Accounts scopes.
And you see storage-rw there.
That's actually an alias for
a full OAuth 2 scope.
And then when you SSH into that
machine, you can start
running the Google
Storage Utility.
It's actually modified to
automatically grab its
credentials from a special
metadata server that's
available only to the
virtual machine.
And you can just seamlessly
communicate with Google
Storage without having to
worry about further
configuration or passwords.
And so this is a great example
of how we've taken these a la
carte services, but made them
actually work well together.
So the next feature here
is Instance Metadata.
So this is a little bit of a
twist on a familiar concept in
the infrastructure world.
But we're providing a set of key
value pairs that you set
at the API that are then
available and exposed into the
virtual machine.
And so in this way, you can take
a single image, and it
can specialize itself at runtime
to do what it needs to
do based on the metadata
that's passed into it.
And so that's exactly how the
Hadoop example that Evan just
showed can take a sort of a
generic image, and from that
bootstrap everything up
to installing Hadoop.
So this metadata is accessible
from within the virtual
machine at a special server
called metadata.
That's very creative.
And this server is a private
HTTP server just for that
virtual machine.
Nobody else sees that metadata
except for that particular
virtual machine.
This is great for configuration
data.
And we also have the support
for project-wide metadata.
And so you can set a key value
pair that will then get
inherited into all of
these instances.
And so this is the mechanism
that we use to push your SSH
keys into the virtual machine
at boot up time.
So there's nothing magical
going on there.
Just start default image, knows
how to read a special
metadata value called SSH keys,
and then goes through
and installs those into
the virtual machine.
Now, here again is a
little bit code to
show how this works.
So here, we're launching an
instance, and we're providing
two metadata values here.
One of them is a simple key
value pair with some short
strings called role
and master.
And then the other one,
the key is config.
And then the actual contents of
that is in this text file
called confic.txt.
And then what you can do is
from within the virtual
machine here you can actually
go through and hit up this
metadata server.
Curl is a simple utility that
downloads from HTTP from the
command line, and you get
that metadata back.
It's a pretty simple concept
but it's really, really
powerful for customizing virtual
machines at boot time.
So we've built on top of this
further with this idea called
Start Up Scripts.
And this utilizes both the
metadata and support that
we've built into the virtual
machine, such that you can
provide essentially a program
that gets run on startup.
It's very similar to rc.local
if you're familiar with Unix
startup semantics.
And so you can use this to
install your software, to grab
binaries or code or do get
[? sink ?] and build or
whatever you need to
do as part of this.
But it's also very useful for
bootstrapping more functional,
more complicated and
comprehensive management
frameworks.
So it's just enough to get you
started and then you can just
take it from there.
So here's an example.
So we're taking that original
example of the Sierpinski
gasket that Evan did.
And I've got to commend him for
actually doing a demo with
a word like Sierpinski in it.
And we're specifying all that
as a startup script.
And so this virtual machine
will boot and it'll
immediately start executing
this code.
And if you want to actually see
what's happening, go in
there and touch it
and feel it.
You can actually SSH in.
And you can actually look at
a log of what's going on.
So we actually saved that data
away for debugging purposes.
Now, when you add all this stuff
together, we're actually
talking about sort of a change
in how you think about
building things from thinking
about building servers to
building services.
And this helps deal with the
reality of what it means to
run in a data center.
Software and hardware
will fail.
And if you can launch more
machines, if you can deal with
more hardware, you're going to
have a lot more exposure to
that failure.
And so something that becomes
a once in awhile
event becomes a--
it happens more often
than you would like.
Hopefully not that often.
So we really want people to use
patterns where they build
across zones.
They think about using that
ephemeral disk as really a
cache or a scratch area.
You build automation, either
through building your own
systems , building on top of App
Engine, which is a great
infrastructure for building the
automation to manage this
stuff, or by using one of our
partners like RightScale, or
Puppet, or Opscode to do this
stuff or any number of open
source projects that are built
to do this type of
orchestration role.
Now, one other thing that I want
to mention here is that
during our limited preview,
we're going to have these
things that we're calling
maintenance windows, where
we're actually going to be
updating both are our hardware
and software in the data centers
that we're running in.
And so this will be up to two
weeks every 20 weeks.
We're going to work
to keep these
things as short as possible.
We're only going to do one at a
time we're going to give you
plenty of warning.
But I think this is an example
of what it means to actually
be in a data center and having
to deal with regular
maintenance.
We're going to be addressing
this in future visions.
This is not something that is
going to be a long-term
quality of the system.
And so with that, I'd like to
invite you all to apply to our
limited preview program.
Like I said, we're starting
with large scale computes.
And as we are able to build
out our capability to take
customers on, we'll be expanding
that and we'll be
expanding the number
of customers.
So if anybody has any
questions, I'd
love to answer them.
And there's Evan, and
the other team
members are here also.
Step up to the microphone.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I have a question.
How about, perhaps not now but
later, government compliance
for the data transport and
all that kind of thing?
Government, like a HIPAA or
something like that, PCI
compliance.
JOE BEDA: Craig, do you
want to answer this?
So I'd like to introduce--
Craig McLuckie is the lead
product manager for Google
Compute Engine.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Hey,
how are you doing?
So the question was
around compliance?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the question is
basically do you guys plan
or have already some sort of
compliance certification like
the HIPAA or something
like that?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: That's
a great question.
Obviously, for a lot
of businesses,
compliance is critical.
At this point we haven't
started focusing on
compliance-related issues.
It's something we'll absolutely
consider as we move forward.
But I can't actually make
any clean statements
about that right now.
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
Where is the key for
the persistent
storage being stored?
JOE BEDA: What is the key?
Deep experience with running
distributed systems--
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Sorry, I think
the question was where is the
key being stored.
JOE BEDA: Oh, where's the key?
Oh, OK.
So what is the key or
where is the key.
So we store that in our
management infrastructure.
But Google has a bunch of
systems in place to actually
isolate and further encrypt that
key to control it with
key rotation policies.
And I think this really comes
back to the compliance issue.
I mean that's the type of
thing that we'd like to
document and provide some
exposure into as we move down
those paths.
But we're very careful to make
sure that we control access to
that key and securely know
how to delete it.
AUDIENCE: My second
question is--
I know with Google App Engine
you have the scheduler that'll
spin up new instances based
on a load balancer
and a number of hits.
Since you have public facing
IPs, is there a plan to have
some sort of a load balancer to
push into that or are they
just going to be more
back end instances?
JOE BEDA: So this is definitely
a feature that
we're missing right now.
And it's one of the reasons
why we're concentrating on
these batch workloads.
And as we continue to develop
the product, that's the type
of thing that we're going
to want to address.
AUDIENCE: And you're using BGP
to get the traffic off the net
onto your local networks
and route it into the--
JOE BEDA: Actually what we're
doing is we're advertising all
these IP addresses
with anycast.
And no matter where they are
we get them onto Google's
network and then we encapsulate
it and then
forward it on with your
virtual network.
So yeah, there's BGP to get the
data as soon as possible.
But we're actually--
like I said, anywhere in the
world we try and get it on our
network as fast as possible.
AUDIENCE: I have another
question.
When you provision a project,
does that provision the
virtual private network
automatically for you?
So any instance in that project
will automatically be
part of that virtual
private network?
JOE BEDA: Yeah, there's a little
bit of detail that I
glossed over.
And if you dig into the API
docs, you'll see this.
You can actually have multiple
virtual networks, as many as
you want, in your project.
We create one called Default by
default, and all our tools
are built to reference that
project by default.
We find that most users
don't need more than
the one virtual network.
But there's going to be a couple
situation where you're
going to want to have separate
VMs running their own isolated
virtual networks.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick follow-up
question to that.
I believe you said that all the
instances across different
regions in that project will
be covered under the same
virtual private network?
JOE BEDA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And then
that never--
or almost never I suppose--
hits the actual internet?
It goes through your
pipeline, right?
JOE BEDA: Exactly.
So if you're communicating
between two virtual machines
over this private network, this
private virtual network
across regions, it will
stay within Google's
network as we do that.
And we can provide a much more
consistent experience and much
more secure and sort of easy
by default experience with
moving data between regions.
AUDIENCE: If I launch, say,
four instances, is there a
guarantee they won't be
on the same hardware?
Or is there some risk I could
end up running all my VMs on
the same piece of equipment?
JOE BEDA: That's a
great question.
I think we try hard to make
sure that doesn't
happen right now.
We don't offer any guarantees.
But that's definitely
something that
we're thinking about.
EVAN ANDERSON: I don't know that
I could actually do that
on purpose if I wanted to
but there's a chance.
JOE BEDA: What's that?
EVAN ANDERSON: I was saying that
I don't know that I could
actually get four-- you know,
if launched four virtual
machines from the API, that I
could get them to land on the
same machine if I tried.
But there's a chance.
JOE BEDA: I mean just to be
clear, for our own testing we
do sort of what we call stack
testing, where we try and load
as many VMs as possible on a
single physical machine to
test out this consistency.
And we've had to do some
specialized things to actually
force them to land on the same
machine for those cases.
AUDIENCE: Can I specify the IP
space within my project?
JOE BEDA: The IP space for
the virtual network?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JOE BEDA: Yes you can specify,
I believe, any 1918 IP space.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And then within a project or--
so the use case I'm thinking
about is I have development
teams, and I want to basically
give them a project.
And they need to talk
to each other.
Can I isolate one development
team from terminating
resources and instances in
another project based on some
sort of a role or--
EVAN ANDERSON: If those two--
if you have two separate
projects, they will be
isolated from each other.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So and what if I wanted
the two projects to
talk to each other?
Should I not use
projects then?
Should I use one
project with--
JOE BEDA: So what you can do
is you can actually add the
service account from one project
to the team of the
other project.
And so you can give one project
permission to actually
call the Compute Engine API
of the other project.
And so the interesting thing
about Service Accounts is you
can add them to any
other [INAUDIBLE].
It's really sort of like
a synthetic user.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that
you can mount a persistent
storage device read, write on a
single instance or read only
on multiple instances.
Can you do that simultaneously?
Read, write on one and--
EVAN ANDERSON: No.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So it's read only on all and
then you have to unmount--
EVAN ANDERSON: Linux doesn't
like it when you do that.
JOE BEDA: Yeah, there are
specialized file systems that
actually do deal with multiple
parties partying on the same
disk at the same time.
It's relatively esoteric.
And one of the ways that
we can get the type of
performance that we can is by
doing fairly aggressive sort
of caching and mapping
on the same machine
as the virtual machine.
AUDIENCE: Hey, is it possibly to
run Asterisk on top off the
Compute Engine?
JOE BEDA: I don't know if
anybody has, but there should
be no reason why you couldn't.
In fact, we were just talking
with one of the members of the
Web RTC team about him using
Compute Engine to actually run
some code to test out real-time
communications.
So that's definitely something
that we think is appropriate
for Compute Engine eventually.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And another question, would we
be getting some free instances
to try it out?
JOE BEDA: So Craig?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: So yeah,
so we invite you to
apply to the program.
So we have a program, which is
a limited preview program.
And folks that we accept into
that program will absolutely
get some free instances.
Now, obviously, there's a pretty
high demand for free
compute, so we can't give it
to everybody right away.
So please do apply to the
program and just give a little
description of the specifics
of the workload.
And we'll put you
into the queue.
And as soon as we can
service that, we
will offer you access.
EVAN ANDERSON: We also want to
make sure that our first
customers for the limited
preview have a really good
support experience, as well.
So that's another reason why
we're limiting the total
number of people
to start with.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I would like to
know how much is the lag
between the App Engine and the
service, and if it's feasible
to tie the [INAUDIBLE]
that is running the instances
with my App Engine up?
JOE BEDA: I'm sorry.
I didn't quite understand.
So App Engine and
Compute Engine--
AUDIENCE: How much is the lag?
JOE BEDA: Oh the lag.
AUDIENCE: Like the round
trip between--?
JOE BEDA: So Adam did some
experiments recently, I think.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: We don't
have numbers we can
publish right now.
What we can say is that a lot of
our early partners and our
early customers that have used
the service have been
extremely impressed by our very
high-speed global network
backbone that all of this
is running over.
So we don't make any strong
guarantees about that latency.
But our early users have been
consistently impressed with
their ability to access other
services like Google App
Engine, or a Google storage
product, or anything else
that's in the Google portfolio
of technologies.
So if you have access, do try
it out and let us know.
JOE BEDA: And with that, I
think we're out of time.
I thank everybody for coming.
Feel free to grab us--
do we have the booth tomorrow?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Yeah,
we've got the booth.
So stop by, say hello.
JOE BEDA: So yeah, I really
enjoy answering the questions,
and I want to continue doing
so, but we're out of time.
Thank you very much.